all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts where
I give my thoughts over morning coffee
so today I want to talk about Twitter
guys I have been tweeting so much lately
it is my favorite app I love this app
oh God it's hilarious
um so before I start don't forget to
like the video on your way in if you
hear any snoring I'm sorry my dog she
gives some snores sometimes
yes so this week I got almost 11 million
views on a tweet
11 million views
also before I start I lost my voice
because I was freestyle rapping so well
this weekend I'm telling you I was
killing this is the bat I'm just excited
to tell you this is the best freestyle
rapping I have done in ages I am getting
good anyways
sorry I'm continuing so
hmm
wisdom would get me 11 million views on
a tweet
you would think I would be saying some
crazy
drop in some crazy knowledge in this day
and age that's a lot of views you got
almost 5 000 quote tweets
um a bunch of retweets bunch of likes uh
I don't have in front of me but this
tweet said
yes you are less attractive as a woman
at 35 than at 25. this used to be common
sense 50 years ago
so essentially what I said
old women are uglier
now I'd like to clarify what I did not
say
I did not say that all 35 year olds are
uglier than 25 year olds nowhere did I
say I was the most attractive 26 year
old on the planet
but what this really showed was female
delusion and narcissism because
I then had women
and this is this is the thing grown
women in their 30s
mad at me so I don't know who this woman
is I'm going to be honest I think she's
famous or something semi I mean not real
famous but like Twitter famous or
I don't know what she I don't care this
isn't a personal attack this is just an
observation
so this is a trump lady some Trump chick
okay
are they extra triggered all right so
she triggers she's a trigger and it's
funny it's like the ladies
that are that are triggered by this
tweet
is talking about how the feminists are
triggered okay all right now she tweets
she says Pearl is 26 and I'm 38. I
believe Pearl believes she is more
attractive than me because she is
younger Pearl looks like a 50 year old
man with long hair Pearl should probably
stop speaking and she goes this picture
of me
wow this picture of her
which is a bit disingenuous can we just
let's talk about this I don't know what
these women look like
like okay I I see a light light editing
looks like some work done these eyebrows
are clearly like painted on I I don't
eat like the crazy thing is these women
attacking me I I don't even know what
they actually look like and I don't care
because this isn't about them
but what I want to point out is this is
a 38 year old I would assume mother
these are the quality of the women that
we have to learn from and the wives
even the conservative ones
this is the quality of the women we have
to learn from and we wonder why
this next generation of women has no
shame
I had over 5 000 quote tweets attacking
my looks I never personally attacked
anybody's looks
and the truth of the matter is
those women would have had more options
at 20 than at 40.
now
the coping continued because I had some
ex fat chicks now I don't this looks
like the crazy thing was I was like is
this another conservative woman
triggered
so she says another one
Pearl this is you in your 20s and me and
my 30s are you sure about that okay
all right crazy ladies
um so who this this woman
um again
what what do you look like a nose job I
think
maybe Buckle fat remove like we can just
see that they've had work done now I
don't really care this isn't like a hate
on women that have had work done but
it's not living in reality because
ladies all right let me let me get like
a chart about looks let me get this
I need a piece of paper okay
and I'm probably gonna have to do a
whole Whiteboard video on this and I'd
like to say all these women I'm pointing
out they attacked me first I have no
sympathy for you if you're gonna attack
me first
so let's just say this is our lifespan
okay and we hit Peak hotness you know
I'm gonna be generous today I'm gonna
say 24 it's our Peak hotness
for me I really think it was 19 but you
know and let's just do 30 here
35 here for a woman 40 here and like
this after 40 it's just like no man's
land
um so
and I'd like to give credit Rolo has a
way better chart of this than me
so what we do
is this is our hotness
okay
now
some women start above this chart right
so maybe they they have they have a
little bit more leeway okay they start a
bit hotter so you know some women start
below this chart
but the curve is still the same for them
okay the curve is still the same when it
comes to being hot okay okay
now
um
let's talk about geriatric pregnancy
starts at 35.
so even with this woman who's I don't
even know
um all right the one says she's 38.
let's say I'm the ugliest chick on the
planet I'm just so ugly they all just
think and
I wake up
and I'm let's just say let's give me a
three okay you know what let's shits and
giggles give me a three
no I'm gonna give me a four I'm gonna be
nice I'm a four okay I'm just an ugly
old four
at 26 and let's just say that lady
I mean honestly these all girls all look
like sixes to me but let's give her an
eight let's be nice today give her an a
I'm a four she's an eight
at 35
38 it doesn't matter
even out of four at 26 I am still a
better pick
then an 8 at 38. for a man that wants
children
because you can look how you want but it
does not change a fertility and it
doesn't change biology and men are
biologically wired to like younger women
now the problem that we get into is with
this chart right the women get to cheat
a little bit so what they'll do is
they'll they'll get into really good
shape and get some plastic surgery
and they'll maybe slow this down I'm
gonna do like a chart
like let's just say that's the dotted
line you see that so maybe they don't
drop off as quickly
but the problem is this this right here
is delusion and it's lying
because you're putting in Botox
lip filler
BBL
um Botox lip filler BBL filters
makeup I'm gonna just list all this
and guys shapewear
uh fake eyebrows
um
what else do they do the gym is natural
give you guys that
um
I don't know fashion whatever it is
and then what you'll do what you guys
will do is say hey hey hey hey
I look better than the 25 year olds Well
ma'am it's because you're a liar
and that's no and nobody knows what you
actually look like like women have
gotten so deluded that they think that
because they put all the on their
face that they actually look like this
they think because they froze their face
and they can't move their eyebrows that
thou now they are a higher quality wife
and mother and it's so crazy because you
get this from the left and the right
which is why sometimes I'm telling you
this space is very alienating because
these women are living in la la land
with their fake faces thinking they're
hotter than they are and it doesn't
really matter how hot you are you can't
change biology and the fact of the
matter is
a chick that's a four probably has more
options than you when it comes to a man
without wants a family
and the other thing is women will say
where are the good men where are the
honest men with all this on their
face
all of this nonsense and then say Oh
now
a couple women will say no I want to
show you this other chick this one
no okay this chick this chick now she's
saying she's hotter than me whatever
good now this was her in her 20s
this is her now
let's zoom in her face was better
looking
in my opinion anyways
it's like the skin is like thicker she's
got like kind eyes you know this like
it's like a fake Beauty I don't know how
to describe it but
regardless if she's a fatty in her 20s
then she really like she thinks she got
hotter right but really she just ruined
her 20s Beauty so she this girl went
from like
here
you know like honestly she kind of just
stayed the same
or maybe maybe she was a little hotter
but like I mean here and then maybe she
got hotter she got into better shape
okay so whatever she goes a little
hotter but she still wasted her 20s
Beauty so in her 20s she could have been
up here but she was here so it's not
that she got hotter it's that she
stopped wasting her beauty and her youth
um because essentially she had a
thousand dollar let's say a thousand
Beauty points she had a thousand dollars
in the store and
she basically spent five hundred dollars
off the bat you know then she went to
the gym and made you know 150 bucks back
and thinks she's hotter
um when really she just wasted her
beauty
and this is all common sense and the
crazy thing is I wasn't even comparing
my looks I was saying that any woman is
hotter in her 20s than her 30s assuming
she didn't piss her youth away waste her
use youth being fat
um now then I got another one this this
this lady these crazy chicks
now honestly who do you think would have
more dates this Sorry my phone's black
and white guys this one
or this who who would have more high
quality men interested in her
and then some of you guys were just
but to me this just shows how deluded we
are as a society these are the wives and
the mothers that are giving us advice
this is who we have to listen to women
that genuinely think they're equally as
hot in their 30s as they were in their
20s you are not supposed to move the
same in your 30s
but we have modern women that move
exactly like they moved in their 20s
and wonder why young women are so misled
and confused because we have these old
chicks
a lot of times married is the crazy part
to husbands they clearly don't like
because
let's be honest let's be honest
if they had husbands that they liked
why would they be so adamant that they
need to be as attractive in their 20s
who cares
who cares if you're as attractive if
your husband likes the way you look
but this is the world we're living in
where
they'll attack my looks for days I'll
play come on guys really really
I'm not even trying to be mean but some
of you I'm like really
are you this deluded all right all right
so
this shows how common narcissism is
think about it they read my Tweet and
thought
the world needs another picture of me
yes I need to prove Pearl wrong Pearl
doesn't know what she's talking about
the world just needs to know that women
in our 30s are just as hot as women in
our 20s I need to prove Pearl that I'm
hotter than her like what level of
narcissism and delusion do you have to
be at
Pearl Pearl I'm hotter like imagine this
is a wife and a mother
and I'm just thinking this in real time
I say hey men like hot young chicks they
prefer 25 year olds as to oh as opposed
to 35 year olds and the the wife and
mother says
and usually like these wives and mothers
are sipping their lattes
foreign
I'm equally as hot
here's my face to prove it I'm better
looking than you perhaps like these
ladies are weirdos so
my point is this
women are so deluded and narcissistic in
modern society because we've had our
egos pumped up by social media
and because we can put all this fake
on our face and believe that we are
actually that hot genuinely believe that
we are actually that hot
um and believe we actually look like the
botox the fillers the fake teeth all of
that
um to the point that we are so
narcissistic
that women in their 30s think they're
hotter than women in their 20s
um you know
cats out of the bag you guys aren't you
are all crazy
and you're proving my point let me know
maybe I'm wrong though let me know what
you guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel I'll talk to you next time